i believe trust usurps love that it
ranks higher if you had to like rank the
conditions that need to exist for
relationships to thrive to survive to
last i just think trust ranks number one
i think people routinely end
relationships with people they love all
of the time
matthew frey welcome to the show
hey thank you so much i'm really happy
to be here appreciate your time
how did you end up being here talking
about divorce
in 2013 my marriage ended and
i don't want to say that i didn't see it
coming because there was an 18-month
lead up to it where it was sort of like
a slow decay and it was pretty awful and
we were in different bedrooms but there
still was nothing that had prepared me
for the experience of my wife literally
like moving out packing a suitcase
taking her little boy i always want to
make sure that people don't imagine like
an angry woman kidnapping our child she
very peacefully and and and promising me
that i'd see him tomorrow or the next
day you know drove and said i'm going to
be at my mom's
that's what it was i don't want to make
it seem like she was a kidnap kidnapping
her son but but she left and it was
brutal and i had a really difficult time
with it we'd been together for 12 years
married for nine of them and i i was 34
at the time just about and
i don't know it i never had like a frame
of reference for anything that sucked
that bad before that was that sort of
awful
and
that was it it was it was my personal
crisis the
everybody can only know what they know
everybody can only have experienced
whatever um adversity or pain that
they've experienced then i don't want to
make excuses for my relatively
non-resilient fragile life up to that
point but it was simply the most
difficult thing i'd encountered
i i hated it and i had to get to work on
figuring out
what i'd done to contribute to it i
needed to selfishly protect my future
self from having this happen again and
in that process i believe i sort of
evolved and came to some valuable
insights and conclusions about ways in
which i had a lot more power and
influence in my relationship than i
believed on the day she drove away where
i felt like a victim and i don't feel
like a victim anymore
it's interesting that you talk about the
exit being uh
unceremonial
unspectacular you know it was there
wasn't it wasn't a someone threw a glass
and then she stormed out and this that
and the other and i think you mentioned
about how you think most relationships
end with a whimper rather than a bang
yeah i think that there is
i mean i don't i don't like to try to
speak for everybody i'll speak for me
and trust that lots of people also
thought and felt this way growing up
when marriages ended and i heard about
it i always assumed somebody had done
something sort of overtly horrible
sexual infidelity physical abuse a crime
you know just
major deceit something something really
bad that we would all like sit around
the table and agree man they definitely
should have ended their marriage because
of that awful thing that person did
and what i've come to believe in my work
and in my personal life is that the
great majority of relationships do not
end that way that they end from things
that people want to fight about whether
they should end over them and those are
conversations around somebody leaving a
dish by the sink or a piece of laundry
on the bedroom floor or the state of the
the bathroom when somebody walks into it
you know after somebody got ready and
brushed their teeth in the morning and
these are the little things that are so
easy to write off as benign as
inconsequential as no big deal and
because one person cares about it
because the other person insists that
it's not a problem
the
it never gets repaired the the
disharmony never heals never gets
repaired and it's my strong belief that
those pile up hundreds of times
thousands of times over the duration of
a relationship they erode trust in a way
that i think of as like a paper cut each
time and that the accumulation of these
paper cuts compromises the stability the
integrity of the relationship and then
you know often it's something
really overtly bad does happen and i
don't necessarily mean infidelity or
something but like an external trauma
like uh
often the death of a loved one or or um
sickness you know somebody gets
diagnosed with like a really scary
disease
and those break relationships in which
the foundation of like safety and trust
has been eroded the resiliency has
already been damaged and then something
heavy enough comes in that can snap that
that's what i believe the most common
story and relationships are but again
it's often not
it doesn't even require the big thing it
doesn't require the the health diagnosis
or or the death in the family or
anything like that it we can absolutely
destroy you know relationships in these
super slow ways and finally somebody has
enough somebody has enough data points
to say this is going to happen forever
so i either have to voluntarily agree to
stay in it or i have to leave
and i think
i hate to say this because so many
people take it as if i'm blaming men i'm
not blaming men i think most men are
exceedingly decent people i think they
miscalculate for how much pain
their partner experiences because of
things they do or don't do that they're
not even really aware of so often i
think men are sort of inadvertently
putting their wives or girlfriends in a
position in heteronormative
relationships um to like to make that
decision and um it's a tough spot for
people to be
yeah it's
the blame game which kind of is very
common on the internet is something that
i i really tried to steer out of a lot
um you know the sort of manosphere slash
red pill and then the kind of whatever
most recent wave of feminism slash women
go in their own way movement
both of these
are
they they have kernels of truth in them
but the problem is that they
look at the problem through a two res
low resolution uh viewpoint right it's
all women are ex or all menorahs or this
is the way to deal with the situation
nobody should get married because it's a
complete waste of time the entire
institution of marriage is skewed
against men or you need to be completely
never open yourself up to men because
men are going to be this sort of using
abusing force and you go okay like look
to me that doesn't seem like it moves us
any closer to a
a useful
outcome and i think that
one of the fundamental things i learned
from david buss who's an evolutionary
psychologist one of the fathers of
evolutionary psychology is that he
there are different ways that men and
women can interpret the same situation
and this isn't something conscious right
uh there's an overestimation and an
undirect
estimation bias when it comes to
attraction so you can have the same
interaction go from a man to a woman and
a woman to a man they're both
experiencing the same thing in terms of
self-report afterwards the man presumes
that the woman was way more interested
in him than she was and the woman
presumes that the man was way less
interested in her than he was and you
can scale this out replicably it's been
done at speed dating competition so on
and so forth that's kind of like a i
don't know like a funny relatively
harmless example but roll that clock
forward that kind of starts to explain
how the boss
might have seen the receptionist as
actually having linked her eyes have
lingered on him a little bit too long
and then that
signal begins to get confused she
thought she was being polite he thought
she was being sort of flirty and you go
okay so who's in the wrong here you go
well
kind of not really anybody because both
people acted on the situation that they
saw right and this is what we're talking
about uh how i'm inferring that you're
talking about the symbolic significance
of leaving glasses on the sink that to
one person the language of leaving
glasses on the sink doesn't mean
anything at all and to another person
what how they interpret that situation
is it's a it's a really really big deal
and
understanding that men and women see the
same situations in different ways is
just such a great hack for dissolving
conflict because what we presume is hang
on
this upset me
how can you not see that this would
upset you too
because i'm not seeing the same thing
that you're seeing
yes
yeah i i posit that at the root of trust
erosion in relationships is one person
saying hey this upsets me or hurts me on
some level and the other person
indicating that they shouldn't think or
feel the thing that they do essentially
saying
that shouldn't matter to you that
shouldn't be as painful or as important
as you're making it out to be and so and
when it's something that i did or didn't
do
i just believe over time our partner
doesn't trust this anymore you know i
liken this scenario to the analogy or
the metaphor that i use in the book is
the idea of the field of optometry back
in the 1700s we hadn't scientifically
proven colorblindness yet so it's
conceivable that two people one person
with color correct vision one person
with color blindness could be standing
there having a very honest debate about
the color of a painting or a bushel of
vegetables or a field of flowers and
both would be telling like the whole
truth but you can just sort of in your
own mind like
see how these two people could come to
you know fight and call each other names
and have an enormous amount of conflict
because you'd believe that
this person has to be intentionally like
screwing with you in order to have
arrived at this conclusion and it's you
know feels deeply insulting to say that
things orange when i know it's green
i know it's green i see it right now
it's there and it's funny right because
there's all sorts of like funny little
things on the internet where people hear
different things or they see a different
color and there's been sort of like
famous examples of that in the last i
don't know 10 years in pop culture but i
i like to imagine like the optometry
fairy this like
wizard of oz like good witch of the
north shows up out of the sky and like
hands the people the glasses that would
allow them to see the color that the
other person saw or hell just be there
for optometrists being able to verify
and whatever scientific method they use
to verify it that people literally see
different colors
because nobody had a frame of reference
for that possibility and i essentially
think that's what we're talking about in
relationships i do think it manifests as
like men do this women do that a lot i i
think there are examples where it's not
always that way where so i try not to
like exclude people i try really hard
not to say men are always like doing
saying thinking feeling this and women
are doing the opposite everything should
be caveated with
on average yes beforehand absolutely and
that's how i think about it it's sort of
like statistically observably true most
of the time
yeah i mean that's just like how i think
about it and i think it's really
important it is that is the idea that
started me on this path
i was was that framework was that their
other humans
literally see and think and feel
different things and that sounds so
ridiculous to emotionally intelligent
naturally empathetic people but when
you're me where i'm from
that is a foreign concept that another
person could describe something 100
differently than me and both could be
true still be telling the truth yeah
it's not something that i understood how
have you come to see the relationship
between trust and love
i believe in the context of a romantic
relationship that
a lot of people think love
is is the the end-all be-all is the
thing that you need that if you have
enough love in place everything's going
to be okay and i don't believe that i
believe trust usurps love that it ranks
higher if you had to like rank the
conditions that need to exist for
relationships to thrive to survive to
last i just think trust ranks number one
i think people routinely end
relationships with people they love all
of the time because of a lack of trust
yeah but yes and again and it's not and
i think a lot of people hear that word
trust and they think well gee i don't
lie i don't cheat
i'm a reliable person that goes to work
and makes money and comes home and i
don't gamble it away what are they
talking about and it shows up in these
really nuanced subtle conversations
where one person sees orange the other
person sees green they're like i see
this differently than you more give us
an example of that well okay so it's
let's just the my most famous example is
the dish by the sink and i insisted that
it was ridiculous
for my wife to make a big deal out of a
dishland by the sink essentially and i
don't wanna a lot of people think this
is a literal conversation about dishes
and that it was some slob that she had
to pick up after me all the time and
that's not true it was a drinking glass
that i put water in so i could take like
vitamins and stuff in the morning and so
i'd set it there just because it felt
like an efficient way to go about it and
i didn't think it was this
i just thought it was ridiculous that
she like kept like sort of like getting
on me about it
the thing that hurts is not the dish
being there
it's not
the thing that hurts is when somebody
feels as if you've promised to love and
care for them and be their adult partner
always
and you simply have no respect and do
not value what they think what they feel
what their experiences are
the dish communicates i'm going to
choose me my beliefs and my feelings my
wants my needs i'm going to choose them
over you every time
our experiences don't align with one
another every time i don't agree
with the thing you're asking for the
thing that you want the thing that you
wish i do different if i don't approve
of the message if i don't concur
i'm gonna do what i want
even at the expense of what you think of
what you feel
and i think that you can get away with
that
hundreds of times probably but i believe
these are the subtle paper cut moments
that destroy trust intimacy and
relationships and finally a person says
to themselves okay this let me just make
it about my marriage my wife finally
learned that if i didn't agree with
whatever she believed or whatever she
felt
that i was always going to choose me
over her
and that's where the trust like it goes
away it's it's not trust
and in terms of honesty it's trust in
terms of reliable reliability
sustainability consistency it is i don't
trust this relationship's going to last
or
even if the relationship does last i
calculate it's going to be even worse
for me down the road than it is today
that's a dangerous place to put people
in people will people people that have a
healthy amount of self-respect and
self-love will exit a relationship in
which they predict a year from now is
going to be worse than today five years
from now is going to be worse than today
anyway and i think we inadvertently put
people in that situation a lot what
about the archetype of the person who
knows that the relationship is already
doomed to fail but then doesn't have the
bravery to leave
this seems to be that seems to be a very
very common uh
situation that i see
yeah no fair enough
the one i imagine and i'd love to hear
different ones that you imagine the one
i imagine when you say that
is and this is pretty stereotypical is
because 7 out of 10 at least in the
united states 7 out of 10 divorces are
filed by women so statistically
you know women are being fed up in my
estimation because of these sort of like
subtle moments of trust erosion and
eventually they work up the courage to
file for divorce but there might be a
number of months or years prior to that
decision right where they held on and
i'm pretty generous about it i think
it's usually i'm staying together for my
children
um i'm staying together it could be
fear-based i'm staying together because
i don't know what his reaction is going
to be
i think
for me one of the ones that i would
definitely see in the modern world uh
financial reliance
uh you know it's increasingly difficult
to be a single person
supporting a household potentially with
kids or without kids sticking together
for the children sticking together
because of a fear of what comes next you
know i don't have the support structure
that i should do you know we've got a
world which is
connected more than ever before and yet
more isolated than it's ever been as
well so people you know you can't go and
live with your facebook friend
and
yeah you're probably right when we're
talking about this given the fact that
seven out of ten divorces
instigated by women if we're talking
about somebody that kind of knows the
relationship should end and doesn't on
average that's probably going to be
women as well and i'd be really
interested for the women that are
watching to throw in the comments below
or do whatever because you know if
you've stuck about in a relationship i
i'd be very interested to work out
what compelled you to stay and what what
didn't compel you to go
um but one of the interesting things
that i quite like that you come up with
is that uh even good people can be bad
spouses
and that's such a like a lovely way to
frame it and it also highlights the fact
that
this is why i think a lot of the
men
in
some of the sort of manosphere movements
feel particularly embittered because
they didn't do anything wrong in their
vision right they got up they went to
work they didn't cheat on their wife
they came home they tried to pay the
mortgage they tried to be a dis that in
the other um and yet it still didn't
work and yet there was maybe the
papercut syndrome the glasses left on
the side the lack of validation the lack
of sense of belonging that that was
needed to keep this going uh and that
sucks man like that's hard for me to
hear men
going through a situation where they
were doing all of the things that men
were told that they were supposed to do
you're supposed to work hard be right by
your woman
and then there's what there's like this
i don't know
translation error that's occurred which
has meant that men and now
the good man
still wasn't a good husband somehow and
squaring that circle
it's it's tough and it's tough for the
woman as well you know i think that a
lot of women are probably pretty
empathetic and they know
look this is a man who's working this is
a man who's trying to provide for me and
yet slowly over time the way that i feel
about him just isn't working and there
isn't anything he didn't cheat on me he
didn't abuse me he didn't spend all of
the money down at the casino and then
tell me that it was on something else
you know it is this whimper not a bang
and this is
i don't know it's so
it's such a bourgeois luxurious way
to to do something catastrophic does
that make sense like it's so comfortable
it's so convenient and yet it's
completely completely atrocious and
painful i i
i wish i could i wish i could prove this
with data i really believe it's the most
common story of relationships that end
and i i hope that that's a hopeful
message what i'm trying to do when i say
good people can be bad spouses
can be bad partners it's it's i'm trying
to disassociate character
from like the behavior i don't think the
harm that's caused in relationships is a
result of anybody
with ill character or ill intention
and what i really hope guys will learn
to do collectively
is stop with the defensive responses
defensiveness is inherently invalidating
and
when somebody says i hurt and then we
make it about us we make it about our
good intentions the person's pain never
gets repaired trust never gets restored
and i know it might seem like a minor
inconsequential moment and i know a lot
of these guys might say well what about
my pain what about my mistrust
it's my belief that we're the first
domino to fall most of the time i will
defend every guy in the world in which i
don't believe he's the first domino to
fall
a man inadvertently does something
he thoughtlessly not and i don't mean
thoughtlessly like carelessly i mean it
doesn't even occur to him because he's
trying to do what he perceives to be his
role in his relationship and his family
doing the right thing often
as a provider often it's like i'm a
provider and i will not cause harm is
more or less like the two pillars on
which he leans and he's always believed
that would be enough and he had every
reason to believe so based on the
feedback of this person that said i do
and that i want to be with you for the
rest of my life and then he goes and
does it but then right while he's like
not paying attention in his blind spots
these little sort of pain points are
occurring these little teeny tiny
moments and they don't get repaired and
when they pile up over the course of 5
10 15 20 years the other person feels so
hurt by this idea that i can't trust
this person to behave in a way where the
math results of their behavior isn't
painful for me and even worse if i try
to say something to about say something
to them about if i try to recruit them
to help like the painful things stop
he gets really defensive or he implies
that i'm wrong that i'm crazy that i'm
stupid that i'm weak that i'm
hypersensitive that i'm too emotional
because he doesn't know how to see the
orange thing that i see as green
or
whatever you know what i mean and
i just think that's a really tragic
story i i really do and i just think we
need to learn how to
value the idea of repair and safety and
trust in our relationships even if the
other person is saying something we
don't calculate to be dangerous to be
harmful
that's like the great lesson
it doesn't matter what our beliefs are
it doesn't matter what our intentions
are the math result of things that
happen in this world or things that we
do absolutely can still result in pain
for other people and we can deny that if
we want i just pause it you won't have
healthy relationships with those people
but feel pain feel free to disagree with
with other people if you don't approve
of the pain that they're claiming to
feel i think if we want to have healthy
relationships we absolutely have to
acknowledge that person's suffering even
if it seems really small
even if it's presenting like really
small like a dish by the sink or a
conversation about laundry
and
the people that learn how to see that
and to acknowledge that and to repair
this teeny tiny moment and not allow
them to accumulate i believe they'll
never have the trust erosion they'll
never do the fallout of love thing
you talk about invalidation and
consideration as
two pillar habits that people need dig
into that for me
um all right so i think the low-hanging
fruit of things that we do in our
relationship
the easiest thing to practice doing
habitually like mechanically to make
things better is to learn how to
validate instead of invalidate and a lot
of guys think that i'm advocating they
hear
that i'm advocating for agreeing with
your relationship partner no matter what
and i promise i'm not doing that and so
what that looked like in my marriage
there's the three distinct ways i refer
to it as the invalidation triple threat
this idea that there are three specific
ways we invalidate somebody even if our
intention is not to invalidate them i
think we think of it as disagreeing
honestly and that we should be allowed
as adults to disagree with other people
and i think we can get away with this
with virtually everybody in our world i
think it will destroy trust and intimacy
with our romantic partners and probably
with our children too um
my wife would come in the room she'd say
hey matt this bad thing happened i feel
bad about it and version one of this
invalidation trouble threat was i
disagreed intellectually with what my
wife is saying happened she'd tell some
story and how it made her feel about it
i'd be like that's not even what
happened this is what happened so
version one is i correct the mental
intellectual experience she had version
two wife walks in the room says hey this
thing happened i feel bad about it and
this time i'm fully on board that the
event happened exactly as she says it
did but now i'm like but why are you
feeling that way about it why are you
allowing that to affect you that much a
more normal or fair or appropriate
reaction to that incident is to feel
this way about it and i try to correct
her feelings this time instead of
whatever she thought and then version
three is just defensiveness hey matt
this happened i feel bad i'm like wait a
minute let me explain let me just try to
explain to you what i was doing and i
feel like once you understand you won't
be mad at me anymore you won't feel like
i did anything to cause harm
and i just believe that the math results
of those three patterns those three
habitual responses that i think are
patterns and relationships
the other person
never gets told i understand that this
situation affected you even if it didn't
affect me
and you can trust me
to like
do something about it moving forward you
can trust me to cooperate that if it's
something that i have the ability to
influence that i'm going to do it
differently moving forward because i
would never allow you to feel hurt
just because i was too comfortable to
like change my ways and i just that's
the thing is i don't think any of these
guys would do that i don't think any of
these guys would truly know
that the wife girlfriend whoever they
love hurts
in a measurable way and say
i'm too comfortable to do things
differently
they literally don't believe
that this scenario is as painful as they
say
so
a lot of guys are like so what do you
want from me you want me to agree with
her i'm like no let's go through this
thought exercise and i i love it when
people are fathers because they identify
with this really easily i'm like let's
please imagine a small child being
afraid of a monster hiding under their
bed so i imagine my son he's 13 now but
he used to be four and he was a threat
when he was four to wake up crying
hysterically because he was afraid of a
monstrous but this didn't literally
happen but it could have absolutely
happened any day and this does happen in
lots of families and we as dad can run
up to that room open the door survey the
scene find out he's upset because he
thinks there's a monster under the bed
and i think the easiest most logical way
to try to solve that problem is to
convince him he's mistaken about the
presence of the monster it's what i used
to do dude there's no monster under the
bed the reason you're crying is isn't
even real
you know you're overreacting right now
you don't need to cry this much
everything's fine
and i might say something thoughtless
like go to sleep you're fine your
bedroom's safe and if i'm not being my
best self and i want to go watch sports
on tv or go back to sleep if it's the
middle of the night go to sleep i don't
have time for invisible monsters right
now and i might leave i think there's
some really important ideas here one i'm
right in this scenario there isn't a
monster there i'm correct
so i i think logic and reason are on my
side and i think that's where a lot of
guys land in these conversations this
belief that they're the logical or the
reasonable ones i think there's a real
danger in leaning on logic and reason in
the context of trust and relationships
um also fact two and three that i can't
prove but i hope you'll believe i love
my son intensely he's my favorite person
on earth and i would never behave in a
manner designed to inflict harm i would
never intentionally do something to her
and i think almost every husband in
world history that truly loves his wife
would say that same thing about his
relationship partner i love her
i i'm right about this and i would never
intentionally do something to hurt her
so i'm just saying there's no monster
under the bed like relax
there's
what's the math result of that situation
though as the dad of this kid
um my son is still afraid of the monster
he still feels fear
whether whether he believes there's
still a monster there are not sort of
irrelevant he's afraid he's still crying
but but now he's abandoned alone in the
dark dad just implied he was dumb he was
crazy he was weak he wasn't good enough
he wasn't behaving the right way when
he's afraid of a monster under the bed
and now what i'm saying is not that he's
right and i'm wrong or vice versa i'm
saying my relationship just took a hit
my relationship suffered and i don't
think that kid if that's how i always
show up when he's suffering on some
level when he feels bad about something
whether it's fear or anger or sadness or
whatever
and that's always how i respond to him
yeah it's not as bad as you're making it
out son toughen up everything's gonna be
okay
i don't think i'm gonna get to have a
healthy relationship with him after
three years after five years after ten
years so this is a choice
and so what's the alternative look like
i think it's i go in that bedroom i hug
my son i say buddy i don't think there's
a monster under there but i'm really
sorry that you're afraid right now i
mean remember we're talking to a
four-year-old in this instance hey i'm
really sorry that you're afraid right
now let's turn a light on let's make
sure there's no monster under the bed
and i think the great lesson and the one
that applies most
symbiotically or whatever with our adult
relationships is the final idea it's son
whenever you're afraid whenever you're
hurt whenever you're sad whenever
something's wrong i want you to know you
can always call mom you can always call
dad and we're going to show up for you
we might not be able to fix what's wrong
we might be able to like solve your
problem for you but you never have to
feel like you're the only one alone like
dealing with this by yourself suffering
in this way we're always going to be by
your side during life's like crappy
moments and
i think that's a profoundly simple yet
powerful idea that we don't communicate
to our adult relationship partners when
we paper cut them with arguments about
dishes and laundry and the state of the
restroom and all sorts of things like i
can't even begin to calculate for all
the little fights different couples have
with one another but i think it's more
or less the equivalent of there's no
monster under the bed so you shouldn't
be afraid and you shouldn't be this
upset with me
it's not useful who's correct or
incorrect it's not what's useful is
responding to somebody in pain
in a manner that restores trust that
increases intimacy that increases safety
and if we can apply that monster under
the bed principle and think about
wanting to have good relationships with
our children we can apply that same idea
to our adult romantic relationships i
think we can practice a habit of
responding to people in a way that's
useful for relationship health instead
of a way that's inadvertently not useful
there's a guy adam lane smith
psychotherapist from the midwest and i
had him on the show last year and he was
talking about how uh male depression and
female depression both get treated like
female depression so female depression
the way that that's supposed to be fixed
is by women being made to feel safe and
comfortable and like they belong and
like they're loved and male depression
gets treated the same way
but that's not what men want they don't
want that sensation what they want is to
feel like they have a purpose and the
ability to achieve it and this is
borne out in the way that men and women
bond as well so women bond through
oxytocin right you have sex that's
the hormone that's released heavily for
women and it is for men too but that's
not one of the primary uh bonding drugs
for them it's vasopressin vasopressin is
released when there is a challenge to
overcome and that men can overcome it as
well and you see this get borne out in
you know the meme about women like
people and men like things like women
are interested in people
and men are interested in things so with
all of this
one of the conversations and for women
that are listening as well like
think about
how he sees the situation
the immediate knee-jerk response is
going to be to try and apply some sort
of rational logic to the situation
to highlight the
hypocrisy or the irrationality or the
illogical nature of whatever it is
that's coming up and for the men you
need to think look it's not even about
that it's not about you you can't fix
this feeling problem with things logic
what you need to do is say look i
understand i hear you i am here you're
validated i i'm listening now let's
slowly step you through this and then if
the reverse happens with a man you know
making him feel like
he's safe and loved and belongs
that might not be the best approach
perhaps for to stress test some of the
things that he's got going on to hear
him to validate him but then to step
through bit by bit with some logic
and again this is women need to speak
man's language and men need to speak
women's language in order to continue to
move forward
it's interesting to me as well the way
that your marriage actually ended i
think that that that story is is
probably pretty useful for people to
hear can you go through that
um you might need to provide some
clarity about exactly what you're asking
decisions why was it her dad
yes thank you thank you no you took me
back the right way i appreciate it yeah
approximately 18 months prior to our
marriage ending
i should go back a little further than
that i don't remember the timeline
exactly but we lost we lost my
father-in-law my my wife's father out of
nowhere completely unexpectedly we'd had
dinner with him the night before and and
the family
they were they were watching our son
was with his grandparents he was only
maybe two years old at the time and so
the five of us the grandparents and my
wife and i and our son in a high chair
were having dinner and it was great and
then the very next night i come home and
i get a call from her cousin saying he
had a heart attack and he's gone oh my
god so i have to go like drop this news
um to her and then the world was insane
for several months because you're
dealing with sort of the grief and the
shock and the loss
and then there's all these sort of
like logistics things that you have to
do when we had to like move her mother
you know somewhere else and and and my
wife at the time was responsible for
that she was like the manager
of trying to clean out and sell the home
that she grew up in that she was born
and raised in and that we still went to
on weekends and things like that and
that had to go away there's so many
layers of sort of
trauma and grief and loss that she was
experiencing while also trying to be a
good daughter to her mother well also
trying to raise our son
and
here she is married to a guy where every
time she's requested
that something be done to alleviate her
of some level of pain or to honor some
some you know pain point for her that
was designed to say i'm i'm respected
i'm safe i'm loved because of this thing
here he's doing you know i didn't do it
for for the better part of a decade
and i just think when a person is put in
that situation
that that's the outside trauma that that
breaks the relationship at least it was
for us
she told me at dinner one night i'm not
sure i love you anymore i'm not sure i
want to be married anymore and i i
pouted and took it really hard and i
moved into the guest room because i
thought she was being unfair i thought
she was betraying me i thought she was
um
that she might be you know thinking
about quitting on our marriage
and i thought you know i hadn't done
anything wrong so you get your you know
you get it together i'm gonna go in the
guest room and and once you straighten
up and figure out what you want you come
tell me about it
and uh
18 months later she packed a suitcase
and left
that was just the 18 most miserable
months of my life where nothing positive
happened
in any way and it's exactly
the most wrong approach about anything
that i've ever done how does it feel to
have
your life direction
upended so much from where you were
expecting to go
well i actually think
other than
the literal loss of the two humans that
you know once lived with me every day
there's there's a real shock when when
people just disappear when they go away
i used to just i used to talk about how
loud the silence could be how loud a
house that used to be full of life
just felt so still and empty it's really
shocking and really unnerving but i
think that's a really powerful question
that you just asked
i felt like divorce had robbed me of my
past
meaning i'd
wasted 12 years of my life in a
relationship that was now gone
and it's like the thought process of the
time is well hell if i knew then what i
know now i would have invested in a
different relationship and i wouldn't
have wasted all this time all these
years but i think maybe the most
significant loss aside from the physical
aside from the literal humans is this
notion of like what's gonna what's
tomorrow gonna be like what's next year
five years ten years from now every
single thought i'd ever had every
daydream about imagining the future
involved my family involved she and i
being old together on a front porch or
whatever you know watching grandkids run
around potentially who knows what it
would be
it's sort of not relevant what it was
what was relevant was the idea that it
takes all of that away
you you everything gets taken away at
least i think people who really truly
value this idea of their marriage and or
their family of being intact and it was
i mean it was a tremendous loss for me i
don't want to whine about it and act
like other people don't have greater
traumas and greater losses they
certainly do
but for me in a relativism way it was
the worst thing that i've ever known and
i think for a lot of people it's the
worst thing they ever know and i think
it's really tragic that the reason they
get there is through a series of things
they're not even paying attention to
what did the process of
uh reintegration into a somewhat normal
life look like over the period after the
divorce
i was just drinking for a while to try
to numb it all
and i called i'd never talked to a
therapist in my life i was sort of
somebody that was like anti therapy i
thought that was something like weak or
crazy people did i was a special guy
like i i needed a lot of help and didn't
know it and
i called this therapist on a 1-800
number
you know half crocked on vodka and
she's like
she said matt you should write you
should write this stuff you should write
your feelings and i'm like okay and she
obviously met journal like an adult um
but instead i just put it on the
internet
and
i didn't think anybody would read it but
once the feedback started rolling in
i got really serious about not being
like
i got really serious about not wanting
to just be
another jerk-off on the internet
bad-mouthing marriage and my ex-wife and
i i needed if i was gonna literally have
an audience that was paying attention to
me i wasn't gonna
take that lightly i was gonna
be committed to trying to do something
positive do something meaningful so
finally i started writing
what i perceived to be vulnerable
stories about like the really the true
process
i was going through mentally emotionally
as i tried to assemble the story of my
marriage
because the one i believed was obviously
not true
i or or at least or at least
my wife's version of the marriage i
didn't understand i needed to understand
something because i needed to protect
myself from having this happen again i
was so afraid
i would end up another 12 15 years from
now and the same thing would happen
again
i was like absolutely terrified that
that could happen so i needed to get it
it was called an insurance policy
and it was extremely empowering to
discover
that all along
i could have made radically different
choices
they would have been subtle though you
know to me they weren't obvious but they
were radically different that i think
would have had like significantly
different outcomes
for the relationship and that's
essentially what my work's based on
today is trying to help people identify
these little everyday moments that they
don't think are a very big deal i
frankly think are
informing the direction of the
relationship and they maybe just don't
hurt enough to realize it yet
you say that feeling respected by one's
wife is essential to living a purposeful
and meaningful life
how is respect built up over time
if you're a man that wants to be
respected
how do you do that is it given is it
earned
i mean i certainly thought i was
entitled to it you know and uh in the
men do this women do this often
dichotomy as we've talked about right
there's this idea of
women wanting to be seen and heard and
understood and cared for and and and
then the quote-unquote man side of the
equation is this idea of having purpose
and and and respect and i i'm glad you
talked i'm glad you talked about this
idea of uh what did you say a challenge
to overcome this idea of having
something to achieve
um i think is really important
i
i think maybe men believe what i
believed that i don't i don't know that
i can answer this in the spirit of the
way that you're asking it
i believed i was entitled to respect
because i never
i never associated
these so-called little things and
relationships
with the idea of being respected it did
they would have never ever been
connected i thought she was wrong yeah
elevate a dish by the sink right to a
marriage problem i have a job i'm
working hard i'm being loyal i'm doing
the things like that's what you're told
that respect comes from yeah it seems
like
you know the the common arc that we're
finding here is
the big things
are still the big things but the little
things can also be the big things too
and
you know you need to as a man cover that
base if you want to ensure that your
partner's going to
feel happy and that you're going to
continue to be respected and i
understand man like i get why there is a
uh
culture on the internet of men that feel
like well look women's standards are
just ridiculous like why is it that i
should have to do all of these things
in order for me to just get the basic
human
uh
like value of respect right and you
think yeah well
fair enough man like maybe that's a
really good question that i don't
particularly have an answer to but
this is these are the rules of the game
you go well why should i have to change
my behavior why can't she change hers
and he goes well
maybe she is maybe there already are
concessions that
as
to
people with penises we can't really like
dip into working out how that happens
but i'm sure that there are lots and
lots of things that women do as well
that they have to make concessions on
and i do understand i understand why it
feels hard for men and then you also see
this seven out of ten divorces are
instigated by women thing
and then you hear these stories about oh
well because you've got an international
dating market that's facilitated by
tinder and only fans and and instagram
it means that what women are doing is
they're just they're
finding the the beater and then moving
on to the alpha and doing all this sort
of stuff
i simply haven't had that experience
reflected in the real world like i i
understand that there are men out there
who have had traumatic situations with
women that have used them that have left
them for people that
were able to offer them more resources
or status or wealth or comfort or
whatever it was that they wanted
validation in life
i haven't
seen that with the women that are going
out with the friends that i i have
around me with the women that i've been
out with it simply doesn't map onto my
experience and i i that gives me hope
and unfortunately
it sounds like um
i don't know it's
like a rich kid saying don't worry about
money
because i i haven't encountered this
problem and i don't disagree that other
people have but my point is that there
are tons and tons and tons of very
healthy
very well-balanced very lovely
women out there that would make
fantastic wives and the same goes for
men and this is
i've had so many of these conversations
recently man like you know imbalances in
the dating market the evolutionary
psychology that underpins why increasing
female achievement with status and
resources and education is making it
ever diffic more difficult for them to
find men that they're fundamentally
attracted to like this is yeah you know
the most interesting dynamic that i've
discovered probably over the last year
uh and like the real core of what i'm
trying to get to is
look
this is a um
ancestrally
limbically psychologically
evolutionarily
psychographically
novel situation for us to be in it is a
new type of environment for everybody to
be in
and yeah maybe it sucks more for some
people than it does for others but like
this toothpaste isn't going back in the
tube like we're not undoing
women outperforming men
in college like what are you gonna do
they've just got equality well you take
it away from them and then like you know
what what politicians running on that
like women we're going to put you back
in the kitchen to make your
relationships better and then
on the flip side of that you go well
why is it that men are the ones that
seem to be suffering in this you know
women are kind of wistfully chasing
after the guys that are across and above
hypergamously and men are the sexless
underclass that don't get to to have any
attention at the bottom you know you
look at the stats on tinder where eighty
percent the bottom eighty percent of men
compete for the bottom twenty percent of
women and the top eighty percent of
women compete for the top twenty percent
of men and you go well look if you're in
the bottom eighty percent of men which
almost all men are because it's the
bottom eighty percent
how's that fair and you go well it's not
i understand that it's not well why
can't women fix their hypergamy and you
go well dude i i
why can't i fly you know why am i why am
i afraid of heights you know all of
these things like there are certain
parts of our biology which are
maladapted to a modern environment and
this for better or for worse right now
is the situation that we're in and i
think that the message i'm really really
trying to get across to people is that a
hopeful view of relationships
is going to be the best thing that you
can do because there's a
an easy cope here right like the cope is
modern relationships and modern dating
is completely [ __ ]
i don't need to invest my time in
finding a woman because fundamentally
they're only bothered about being gold
diggers or blah blah blah blah blah blah
whatever and you go well dude like
don't get me wrong you're probably not
gonna get hurt like
congratulations right you've won the
game of insulating yourself from the
entire world outside congratulations
well done
maybe for some people that genuinely is
a better option um but that inner
citadel that they're retreating to
i don't know like you've got what
[ __ ] 80 years on this planet is that
really
how you're going to progress through the
rest of your days with this defeatist
mentality especially from men that often
talk about you know like overcoming
adversity uh
not being a victim taking on that sort
of victor uh ideal
and you go well look like what would the
victor do he'd showed her a burden you
know he'd pick up a weight and carry it
and i i really really want to try and
have a hopeful view of relationships for
people yes modern dating dating's
difficult yes divorces can suck
but dude like what else are you gonna do
with your time what else are you gonna
do really retreat into this citadel
again no like that's what i want people
to take away like look there is there is
hope and there are
principles i'm adamant that almost
everybody is like one or two principles
away from a radically different life
right if you'd known
two principles from the stuff maybe not
all of them but just a couple of them
you would have a radically different
life and so would pretty much everybody
else and that's the goal of as far as i
can see
sort of this modern
insight sense making wisdom based
communication stuff is like look
where's the pitfalls
how do i avoid them where's the
successes how do i expedite getting
towards them
and whether that be
blending your
finances in the right way we had this
amazing guy on doing data-driven tactics
for accumulating wealth and stuff like
okay should i max my 401k or should i
put it all into the s p or whatever
right like there's a principle right you
just learn the principle or the
principle about communicating with your
spouse or the principal about why you
should go sober 30 days out of every
year or whatever it is
just picking up those principles over
time but yeah the principle about being
hopeful around dating is one that i hope
people take on board
i think so too i really do i want to
address a couple of the things that you
said that i think are really important
um you talked about the idea of men
saying you know why don't women need to
change why does it have to be on me
the thing that i would ask for
a smidge of compassion on the on the
man's side about is
frequently pain
is being experienced by the other person
and pain is not being experienced you're
frustrated you're angry it sucks it's
inconvenient but pain is being
experienced on the other side i think in
the common heteronormative male female
relationship and i i think that's the
chasm between
why do we need to change because i don't
think we should hurt people that we
promise to love i think that's bad even
if we don't mean to i think we should
accept responsibility for doing things
differently so that the math results of
our behavior isn't pain and then on the
side of like
the dating marketplace i just
i don't know i'm a big i'm in favor of
two ideas one accept responsibility for
partner selection i do not
i'm so sorry for guys that felt conned
or duped or misled victims of of
cheaters and liars
um and i don't mean to like hold us up
to some grand standard that that these
guys are like somehow too dumb to have
like been able to avoid but
i've never been in a relationship even a
short little dating relationship with
somebody that i felt conned by
ever
i don't i believe strongly i can avoid i
i know how to ask questions and discern
whether somebody is sort of an awful
evil person or not i'm aware there are
anomalies out there
but i i just i want to be responsible
for for partner selection i just think
it's really really important i'm not and
then so right i'm not going to hurt
somebody and they'd be mad at them that
they don't want to be with me anymore
and if somebody does something awful to
me
well at the end of the day it's still on
me because i chose them
and i really wish people would it's just
empowering i just think a victim
mentality is is really dangerous
to to believe that we don't have any
control over what happens is really
dangerous we have an enormous amount of
influence
be somebody that people want to be with
and i understand that there are
resources and genetics and all sorts of
things that factor into this but at the
end of the day
i want the math results of my behavior
to be attractive or at minimum not
unattractive not something that this so
i meet somebody
i don't want them five years from now to
not want to be with me anymore because
of the math of my behavior
and that's how i think about it and
maybe people think that that's a
ridiculous idea but i don't believe i've
ever met anybody
that
would
trick me would keep me on the line for
five years i
i believe i push them away because of
things i do or don't do and i think
that's the healthy way to think about it
taking responsibility in that way seems
to be
i don't know it's just the more hopeful
way of looking at relationships i had
the
uh
director of behavioral science at hinge
on the show a couple of weeks ago a lady
called logan yuri's just written a new
book
how not to die alone and uh
she said she had
she had some really interesting insights
about she called it uh intentional
dating and um there's something still
icky about that right that uh men that
take how to date courses
like both from men and women that it's a
little bit like well hang on
is this not supposed to be like emergent
and natural and part of your sort of
male charisma like the musk that comes
out of you it's just supposed to exude
from you normally and there's something
i think previously
might be
slowly being degraded now that felt it
was presumed to be a little bit icky
somehow that this felt
not manipulative but deficient in some
way right that it was highlighting the
fact that this man wasn't enough as he
was so therefore he would need
to become more when it's very sort of
it's i think there's something about the
fact it's only one step away from a
narcissist who's sort of playing the
game but not not loving the game so to
speak he's not invested in the game but
he's just learning you know the pick
apart this sort of community of 2000 the
early 2000s kind of laid
the foundations for this
but do being deliberate and intentional
about the way that you date we're
deliberately intentional about
everything else
everybody that's listening to the show
is deliberate intentional about the time
that they go to bed and about the macros
that they eat during the day and about
their hydration and about their training
and the people that they spend time
around and the type of breville sandwich
maker that they use and what note-taking
app they decide that they're going to
optimize their kindle highlights with
and then you get to something like
dating and you're like oh well we'll
just leave it up to mother nature and
you think well
maybe not maybe maybe there is a degree
of where you could be over-intentional
and kind of so deliberate that all of
the love and and presence and grace gets
taken out of stuff but definitely with
this you know one or two principles away
from
something really important happening
um one of the things that i thought was
really really interesting that i wanted
to discuss was that you talked about how
having not been with your wife for quite
a while and not being intimate with her
for a long time even before that
that there was
a
an extra level of existential pain to
think about another man touching her and
this is something that
i think is very very difficult for men
to explain to women
what how this feels
the fact that you can have someone who
you are no longer
intimate with or maybe don't even
particularly have a desire to be
intimate with anymore
and yet there's something in your
programming
that causes you to feel
like this sort of guttural
pull
that some thing or someone that was once
yours
now isn't
sure i i mean i think if it mattered i
i i cared i a lot less today that we're
nine years out now literally
mathematically it was april 1st 2013
when she drove away um
it's
i i really it's not a thing i think
about very much anymore and i even go so
far as to say i like the dude that she's
been with for like five or six years
he's a good guy i i had the experience
of her dating somebody i i wished would
die and i've never wanted anyone to die
before and i mean that
and i didn't really want him to die so
awful i i i don't even think that that's
true i just kind of wouldn't mind if
like an accident had befallen him
i think that was it but so much of it
was about was about my son so much of it
was about like somebody i calculated to
be an awful human being in my son's
sphere and yes i was offended by the
idea that you're talking about that like
this gross person like got to be with
her because that was
what i perceived to be relatively soon
after the marriage ended and i think
there's an important idea here for her
she'd probably been done for a long time
checked out quite 12 to 18 to 24 months
and for me it was like immediate and
right now and people need to understand
that that is like a radically different
experience once again it's the orange i
see orange they see green it's all of
that
but yeah it's pretty bad and i think a
lot of people probably feel really awful
about it when when relationships end
and maybe even like a current dating
partner that perceives you to like still
want your ex
because you're i mean i i was i've been
accused of that um early years ago
that you know i was dated a couple
people there like he still hung up on
his ex and i'm like
really not i hung up on the idea that i
messed up i feel like in my relationship
and that it was the single greatest
sort of misstep in my life and by messed
up i really mean millions of them you
know day in and day out it was like well
you don't know can't kill you that's an
important learning experience right like
it's difficult maybe again this is the
why do women see what a mensee thing not
working that
what you're looking at in retrospect now
is a very valuable learning experience a
strategic learning experience from which
you hopefully can
um
again expedite success and avoid
pitfalls
but from perhaps a woman's perspective
looking at you
still ruminating about situations and
stuff like that it's not about logically
rationally what can you pull out of this
situation it's about
it must be the emotions it must be that
he's still in love with his ex you go
well
no there's a difference and again
on average i have tons and tons of
female friends that are way way more
logical than some of my guy friends but
my point is that i could see how that
would be an interpretation yeah i think
it's really interesting so yeah it was i
wrote about that at the beginning of the
book i was having a really tough time
with thinking about i mean i thought
about it like every day it was really
awful i was like sitting around
miserable drinking vodka just upset and
imagining her doing god knows what with
you know this person that i thought was
awful and that was
the value of it is i don't believe
growth change
evolution if you will occurs until
standing pat until inertia
the pain of inertia
i have to the discomfort has to be
i can't sit still anymore forgive me for
not being able to get this out
i need change is uncomfortable but the
discomfort from the change is less
severe
than the discomfort of doing nothing
because this feels so bad i can't stay
like this ever again that was the only
thing in my life where that had ever
been true about where i had been
motivated to action because it felt the
idea of being stuck of being still of
not doing anything different was too
impossible to imagine i'm like i'm not
going to subject myself to this
identical thing happening again what's
so interesting to me is how
i went this way
and then you talked about like right the
man is fear like red pill guys and i'm
there who i get like the greatest amount
of criticism from if if i have like
intellectual critique of my work it's
from them they believe that i'm
advocating like men being effeminate and
taking blame and i'm
promise i'm not i'm i'm just
we better give a [ __ ] about the
experiences of someone else i don't
really care who we're with i also am not
a marriage advocate don't get married
don't date don't don't do anything you
don't want to do
if if the mission is a relationship with
another human being i don't care who
they are
you better value what they value
the requisite amount
or they're going to choose to not be
with anymore they're not going to trust
you anymore they're not going to
perceive you to be reliable anymore and
then they're going to want to go away
and i don't understand why that is a
uncomfortable concept for people i
invite everyone to test that idea out
for themselves i think it puts a lot of
the onus on the guys if you do that
which is one of the problems so i had
jeffrey miller on the show uh he was
basically the father of the sexual
selection sexual dynamics movement when
it comes to evolutionary psychology so
he's the guy that began the red pill
movement uh from an academic standpoint
right so everybody that's in the
manosphere now that is sort of
promulgating these ideas they're quoting
jeffrey's own work back to him you know
he's the guy that did the studies and he
was writing this in the 90s and then in
2004 he released a book and then in 2013
he released another book called mate
with uh tucker max i have that book yeah
yeah so jeffrey's the the academic uh
rocket power behind that and tucker's
kind of like the the real world
uh
stress testing i guess you could say and
um dude they say inmate they're talking
about and i asked him about this they
spent so much time
in the first chapter of mate explaining
to men this is a book for men how to how
what women want and how to give it to
them something like that like the most
pick apart is the title ever but it's a
fantastic book
and in the first chapter of it they
spend like
five or ten pages
explaining to men what it's like to be a
woman in the dating market like in real
graphic detail like explaining what it
feels like to be physically weaker than
the people that you're choosing to go
out on a date with and what it feels
like to have to
tell your girlfriends
if i don't message you by this time then
you know here's where i'm going to be or
leave and find my iphone on and all of
this sort of stuff just passively bro
because again there is a non-zero number
of men out there that are [ __ ] and
women therefore need to have a
particular protection mechanism in place
what does it feel like to be judged
primarily on your looks that being the
fundamental source of value that you
have on the dating market what does it
feel like to be in competition where
there is um
a
the cash value or the price of sex
continues to be degraded because women
are increasingly prepared to have sex
with less and less commitment from men
because sex has now become decoupled
from having babies and then norms around
casual sexes continue to be degraded and
blah blah blah so if you're a woman who
wants to wait for a few dates that means
that you're playing a game against the
women that don't want to wait for a few
dates because he can go and get sex on
date two but you'll want to make him
make him wait till day four all of these
things pages pages and pages and pages
of these guys
explaining it and i asked jeffrey about
it and he said well yeah this is the
thing that the sort of modern dating
movement that's helping men is missing
which is if you want to be effective in
the dating market as a man
maybe spend a nanosecond
thinking about what it's like to be a
woman what are you optimizing for here
are you optimizing for yourself are you
optimizing for the person that you're
trying to attract and yeah i i can
understand why
the position that you put across is uh
triggering or uh makes men feel
some men in the manosphere still feel
dissatisfied me too because for them
any
uh
any
advocation
that it's not women's fault
is unacceptable right it is almost
always about the fact that women are
overly hypergamous that they're gold
diggers that they're prepared to leave
the beta to [ __ ] the alpha like that's
that's the the um
rubric that just kind of gets thrown at
whatever the situation is
um
and yeah i think you know again like
this is the more to me this is the more
hopeful view man like that there are
solutions out there that there are ways
to optimize your dating life to be
intentional to be deliberate to find
somebody that's good for you that seems
far more hopeful
yeah i hope so and again i i heard
everything you just said and i am
sympathetic backslash empathetic to
those guys
but the the part that that leaves out is
personal responsibility for partner
selection i i just
it's a non-starter in a conversation
with me
if you can't accept responsibility for
the person you're gonna
share space with and share resources
with and potentially share children with
i don't know how to have like
a conversation about that that's
because that if it's all women's fault
then that means you bear no
responsibility in like who you choose to
spend your life with and i i don't
understand that
you said when talking about what
constitutes a good life that a better
word than happiness might be contentment
or peace or balance yeah
maybe
i think you're right
i think when i try and think about what
i optimize my life for it's peace i
don't try and necessarily optimize it
for peak experiences
and this is one of the things that i try
and tell my friends look dude like
there is no value that you can place on
your sanity when you have the decision
to make between
cheating on you on your girlfriend
because there's this like hot chick in a
bar or whatever um and then going back
like look
if you're going to spend the next three
weeks turning yourself inside out
because you can't believe the person
that you were did the thing that you did
that there is no what
a hundred thousand pounds
two hundred thousand pound what would
you pay to get those three weeks of your
life back remembering that time is
something that you're never going to be
able to to reclaim you know you're in
the prime of your life and you've spent
all of this time obsessing over some
terrible situation that you put yourself
in yeah so optimizing for sanity for
peace for contentment for balance that's
what i think people should be moving
toward and then from there you have the
opportunity to build towards something
that's better but that's you know you
can't put a price on sanity and i think
that that's what we should be protecting
as much as we can
it's incredibly valuable insight you
know my experience with that was when my
marriage was falling apart and i was
sleeping in the guest room for 18 months
or the nights afterward where i'd be up
for two three four hours in the middle
of the night just simply unable to sleep
feeling the most miserable i've ever
felt there's nowhere to hide from it
there's nowhere to run away from it
comes to work with you and rides in the
car with you and it does all the things
and um
right i if there was
some
economical way to like exchange money to
make that stop i would have absolutely
traded financial resources for it
um but there isn't and i think there are
probably many many wealthy people out
there that have experienced that that
have had the three four hours of being
unable to sleep in the middle of the
night of trying to concentrate in a high
level executive meeting um but can't
think about anything but like the horse
show at home
and
right it doesn't matter how many zeros
are in their bank account
there's no peace well that's exactly
you know whether it is that we couldn't
pay our way out of it
neither can elon musk that's right you
know there isn't a way to to fix this
the the ultimate cash value of sanity is
infinite
yeah no i think that's really important
to think about and i mean i'm
i'm not perfect i haven't achieved some
incredible state of zen where i feel
good about myself all the time i i don't
mean to imply that
but
in the i believe strongly that healthy
relationships are huge for providing
stability in our lives
and so
being mindful of how we might be
inadvertently like
jeopardizing its integrity jeopardizing
its longevity is a really valuable
thought exercise and something to
consider and practice new habits for
because that is one of the things that
will like just really mess up your life
if you value the stability of the
marriage and family i don't want to
place my values on other people
but if that's i think most people care
about their home life uh being some sort
of oasis from you know the [ __ ] out in
the world
matthew frey ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with what
you do online where should they go
um thank you my home on the internet's
matthewfray.com
just matthew with two tts frey fr a y
and uh yeah i mean there's
every social channel and email address
and things like that if anybody wants to
participate in these conversations to
say oh yeah that's really great or
you're a [ __ ] i'm uh i'm open to either
conversation i promise thanks man i
appreciate it thank you so much i really
appreciate it what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace